- Well I feel like it's only proper
every time I have someone here
from Downton Abbey,
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] that I have high tea,
so Justin will you?
I think it's just proper.
It feels wrong.
(applause)
It feels wrong unless I have it.
- Look at this.
- Look how carefully you are carrying that
you are like "I will not drop this."
- And then the bow and then the bow.
- Get it Justin yeah.
- Oh oh, didn't bow.
- Oh he didn't bow he yeah.
He didn't like us that much.
- Fired.
(laughing)
- So we have all these things for you
- Wonderful.
- biscuits and everything.
- Are you gonna have tea?
- I already have tea as you can tell
allergies have,
they're trying to kill me.
- Okay.
- Allen,
but congrats on the movie.
- Thank you very much.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Thank you.
So this is also a congrats too,
it's baby number two almost right?
- Baby number two I know.
- Are you ready for baby number two?
- I am ready.
You know what?
I'll drink this in a minute.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I am ready.
The one thing that I've noticed
with baby number two when you're
preparing the room,
and you know building all the stuff.
- Yeah.
- Now I have a little person going
"Whatcha doin' daddy?"
(Stammering)
I'm just building this.
"I'll help you?"
No, I'm okay.
And then suddenly all the
little bits go missing.
You know the bits to put it together?
- Yep.
- Yeah she did that the
other day which was fun.
- Is she doing that fun
thing that my eldest did
when my son was born and it was like,
"hmm time's being taken away
from just focus on me?"
- Oh yeah, oh yeah.
She's doing that definitely.
Yeah and any time that it's brought up
suddenly she's on the bump,
kinda lying on it going like,
"What was that?
Talking about me or this?
Oh, it's okay"
Kinda covering it you know?
(Kelly laughing) (Kelly clapping)
- [Kelly] I love that I love that.